[Music]
what other
tools exercises questions do you have
for people
who have trouble spending money now
that might sound strange but ultimately
money is this
piece of symbolism that we trade for
something else
yeah whether it's a feeling or an
experience which is usually
upstream of a yet another feeling you
interviewed a couple
as i understand it that saved millions
of dollars but they seem unable to enjoy
it
yeah they have not had a vacation in the
last decade right or people who struggle
over small expenses
well what are some other tools in the
toolkit or questions approaches that you
use in cases like that and this might
sound really strange to people
like it's rarefied air right they might
be like ah like they're taking this
conversation in a direction that will
not relate to anyone
but that's in my experience not true i
think the
the developing competency and comfort
with
translating dollars into value whether
that is through
investing or spending which is
oftentimes another type of investing i
think is a skill that you
develop i don't think anyone has it
innately right so this applies to many
more but
since i believe you've interviewed this
particular couple what other tools do
you have in the toolkit besides the 100
challenge so first i have a lot of
compassion for them because
everybody teaches us how to save but
nobody teaches us how to spend
spending is a skill and you know my
dream
is to take someone who's made money
and take them out in new york for two or
three days
and show them how to spend money
commensurate with the level that they
are
at now please do not dm me and ask me to
take you out in new york or la
i'm not doing that anymore tim if you
want to do that but i think you spend
money fine but please don't dm me and
ask for
a free tour you know i'll make a
confession just real quick
so i think i am actually it has been
very hard for me to learn how to spend
money
very challenging and in fact i'm
interrupting so don't lose your train of
thought but the reason i'm interrupting
is that literally this past weekend was
the first
maybe the first time ever i have done
like a
proper weekend in
new york city with my girlfriend really
yeah wait is this is this about to
happen
are you and i gonna have a romantic
adventure where i'm gonna
you know we're gonna like go to a
broadway show together
and well i mean i'm i'm open to that i
literally just did this though this past
how did it feel it felt amazing
and uh
it was it was outstanding and we had so
much fun and it brought us closer
and you know there are things we would
do again and some things we wouldn't do
again but ultimately
it was affordable and
like why are we collecting all these m
ms like you can
if not to ultimately use them in some
fashion and that's not to say you don't
save i mean i've spent my whole life
saving
right but as you said like you just
don't you're getting the first piece of
the puzzle but then you have to figure
out the rest of it
please continue so thrilled to hear that
and it doesn't matter whether the amount
is you know ten thousand dollars that
you save
or a much larger amount invariably if
you've been saving
and or investing for a while you will
ultimately have an amount where you have
to decide what to do with it
and most of us spend our entire lives
focusing on just the saving part
but i think probably every single one of
us has a parent
or a relative or somebody older than us
who does not know how to enjoy their
money
and they still drive around town to save
money on gas
and you say look you've got enough what
are you going to do with it and then
ultimately they will say something like
well i guess i'll just give it to my
kids
your kids don't want the money they want
you to have a good life
they want you to spend it on the things
you love and so that's why i'm so
passionate about this
in fairness some of the kids want the
money
but a lot of kids also want their
parents to have a great okay i did not
make an allowance for those people
they're like counting the clock
oh that's sad so you know i have found
that
you cannot tell people who struggle with
spending money
hey guys you really need to spend more
money it's just it goes in one ear and
out the other it's
not even a factor in their life that's
why i spend so much time saying
what's your rich life it's very much
like the same you can't tell someone who
loves chocolate cake
cut out the chocolate cake instead we
say hey let's add a little bit more
delicious chicken
let's add some really good asparagus
yeah you still want the chocolate cake
cool
but it's probably going to just
naturally become a little bit less of a
part on the plate
so when i when i talk about their rich
life when i understand the texture
the color i don't want them to say
travel
i want them to say i'm going to
indonesia for four weeks with my
beautiful wife
we're going to sit in c2a or 2d
and this is where we're going to stay
and this is what we're going to do and
we're even going to have
a food tour and we're going to do this
and that
now it's vivid vivid enough that they
get excited about it
i also use the stick where i say okay
right now you're 38 years old
this was a couple that i spoke to and i
said by my calculations
by the time you're in your 60s you will
have
over 26 million dollars
when are you gonna start spending your
money
and they looked at each other and he
goes well probably when i retire
and i just point blank said to him i
don't believe you do you believe him
and the wife said no i don't believe of
course i don't believe he can't even
spend his money right now
and so what i encouraged them and what i
showed them was
would you rather end up at 60 with
some amount of money or would you rather
end up at 60 with just a little bit less
money but a lifetime worth of experience
ultimately when i'm speaking to people
like this who find it difficult
they're just afraid afraid that they'll
lose it all and as i probed him you know
what he told me
his dad had lost all of his money late
in life
so you often find these family
challenges that they cannot escape from
how did he lose his money do you
remember how did his dad was in another
country
and he made a series of bad investments
and bad deals
and lost it all so they've constantly
lived with this fear
as by the way all of us do based on the
cues we were raised with
that you know i could lose it all or
that i'll never be rich
or that the rich are all evil and those
are some of those invisible scripts that
we have to work through if we want to
work with our partner together towards a
rich life
you